division agents have been made aware of
hostages being held in the Nelson
theater by the hyenas given their
drug-fueled unpredictability agents must
work quickly to rescue the civilians
[Music]
a once vibrant and bustling venue the
Nelson Theater now stands as a fortress
of fear as the hyenas use it as a prison
to hold hostages
a distress call was received by division
agents it was a plea for help without
hesitation the agents accepted their
Duty and prepared for the mission that
lay ahead their objective was clear
rescue the hostages trapped within the
Nelson theater and remove all hyena
prisons
the agents made their way towards the
theater as they approached the compound
they knew they had to act swiftly as to
not allow the hyenas the chance to react
infiltrating the theater they navigated
the corridors to reach the backstage
area where the hostages were being held
captive
however the hyenas weren't going to make
this easy
the agents found themselves face to face
with the ruthless faction a fierce
battle ensued as bullets flew and
explosions rocked the theater's Halls
regardless the agents pushed on taking
down the hyenas one by one
with each enemy defeated they moved
closer to their goal of freeing the
terrified civilians
as they cleared the area the ages
discovered a locked door preventing
access to the hostages
determined to find a way to release them
they searched for a key and this is when
they would be confronted by a
high-ranking hyena called zero
Infamous for a ruthless tactics the
agent's skill and precision proved too
much they would go on to eliminate zero
who happened to be carrying the civilian
key
finally they were able to release the
hostages from the confinement
the agents unlocked the cells freeing
the Innocence
with the mission accomplished and the
hostages rescued the agents guided The
Grateful civilians towards the exit
you're hurting me
Jacoby what did I tell you this Punk
robbed a pharmacy and killed four people
that's I'll take it from here
whatever you say captain
do you need a doctor tried to
break my arm do you want to file a
complaint yeah I want to file a
complaint cops can't treat you like that
officer Jacoby will be dealt with
what's your name you can't believe what
he tells you I didn't do nothing I need
your name for the complaint against
officer Jacoby oh okay Zoe Addison two
D's thank you Miss Allison
now tell me what happened I was coming
out of the pharmacy and that
grabbed me and the four murders you
can't pin that on me I'm gonna need to
put you in a holding cell while we
review the surveillance tapes that
should clear things up you can't trust
the tapes they won't tell you the whole
story I did what I had to do I was
defending myself
Captain Scott interrogate zero who was
accused of robbing a pharmacy and
killing four people zero denies the
accusations and complains about officer
Jacoby's rough treatment
Captain Scott assured zero that officer
Jacoby will be held accountable
Captain Scott says that she will review
the surveillance tapes before making the
final judgment and in form zero they
shall be held in a holding cell during
the investigation
zero insists that she was defending
herself and that the footage won't show
everything
Jacoby I got another excessive force
complaint on you you almost
broke that girl's arm
I know you're tired we're all tired but
we have to still treat people with
respect sorry cap we can't afford to
lose the Public's trust Captain how
would you like us to proceed do your
patrols help civilians keep them safe
arrest people who are breaking the law
if your life is in danger and you have
to use lethal Force use lethal force and
how will we know when it's okay to use
lethal Force de-escalate this arm and
disable rely on your training and use
your better judgment and if you can't do
that then maybe you should think about
taking a break and if I need to
discharge my weapon you'll back me up if
it's Justified
Captain Scott addresses Captain Jacoby
regarding the excessive false complaint
she emphasizes the importance of
treating people with respect and
maintaining the Public's Trust
the officers inquire about the proper
use of force to which Captain Scott
advises de-escalation and relying on
their training and judgment she also
suggests taking a break if needed
Captain Scott assures that she'll
support officers who discharge their
weapon but only if it is Justified
we've got hostiles trying to break into
the station there are too many entrance
points we don't have enough manpower to
control them all we need to fortify the
theater fortify build barricades set up
perch points for snipers close off exits
and entrances make it a fortress that a
two-man crew could defend or should I
also set up cauldrons of burning oil and
a trebuchet oh just get it done Jacoby
officer Jacoby and Forbes Captain Scott
about hostiles attempting to breach the
station due to the fact that the police
was underpowered as it is it was getting
difficult to hold the precinct
Captain Scott ordered her men to take
the inmates and get to the Nelson
theater where it would be easier to
fortify and defend
the police officers were able to fortify
the theater and made cells for the
inmates But as time went by their food
and supplies were beginning to run out
you don't have to do this you left me in
this cell to starve to death
let's go Alex are you used to sing in
the choir shut up at the church of the
Epiphany I said shut up if your mother
could see her little boy now her little
saint I ain't no saint you're better
than this I know you're not gonna shoot
me you're
here I won't shoot you I'm Gonna Leave
You Like You left my girl that's right
ain't no one's coming to rescue you
ain't no one left if you're smart you'll
kill yourself I hear starvation is an
ugly way to go
eventually the hyenas breached the
theater killing most police officers on
site
Captain Scott begged for the mercy of
zero and her hyena boyfriend saint
however zero thought that she had been
left to die in the cell so the two left
Captain Scott to die of starvation
sometime after the events of the Nelson
Theater Saint would be involved in a
hostage situation with the hyenas who
are holding Eleanor Sawyer at the Grand
Washington hotel
Eleanor was the daughter of Odessa
Sawyer former division agent and leader
of the theater settlement
division agents would eventually catch
up to him while rescuing adesa's
daughter
in this classified assignment we're
shown how things are playing out quite
early on possibly before the jtf was
assembled in DC
it looks as though it was at the point
where the police were starting to lose
control of the areas under their watch
their numbers are low and dropping
rapidly and the growing hostile presence
is beginning to overwhelm them
tempers are flaring and exhaustion is
sitting in
officers are in the situation of having
to make some tough calls with only a
moment's notice or their risk becoming
just another fatality of the violence
that is erupting throughout the capital
I wasn't sure how these short videos on
the classified assignments would be
taken since the information is so old
but a lot of you have reached out
thanking me for covering these because
you haven't been able to experience them
yourselves so I'll keep plugging through
them in between larger videos I'm
working on I'll set up a playlist for
them too something I was hoping to work
through for the whole Channel because
they're a bit of a mess right now
anyway thank you very much for watching
and extremist malice extrema remedia
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]